ثلاثة لقاحات لفيروس كوفيد 19 ،
ملايين الجرعات في أحضان
الأمريكيين ،
هذه اللقطات غير مصرح بها
للأطفال في
الوقت الحالي ، نتوقع أن
التجارب السريرية ستعطينا
معلومات أنه بحلول الوقت الذي نصل فيه
إلى الخريف ،
سيكون طلاب المدارس الثانوية قادرين
على ذلك  للتلقيح
، أعلن جونسون وجونسون عن خططه
لدراسة لقاحهما ، ولم يكن
الأطفال المراهقون الذين لديهم فرصة منخفضة جدًا للإصابة
بمرض شديد من
covid19 جزءًا من الاختبارات الأولية في
عملية الموافقة السريعة على
اللقاحات
التي يقول الرئيس التنفيذي للشركة أنها ستبدأ في
الاختبار  في الأشخاص الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 12 و 18 عامًا
وينزلون من هناك ويقولون إنه من المحتمل أن يكون لدى جونسون وجونسون لقاح covid19
متاح لمن تقل أعمارهم عن 18 عامًا
بحلول سبتمبر ، تخضع كل من شركة Pfizer و Moderna
بالفعل لتجارب إكلينيكية
تدرس لقاحاتهم في مرحلة المراهقة
الحديثة وتخطط لدراسة اللقاح  في
الأطفال الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 6
أشهر و 11 عامًا وما أطلق عليه اسم
شركة
فايزر قصيرة الأجل تقول إنه من المتوقع أن تبدأ
اللقاحات  الدراسة في الأطفال الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 5 إلى 11 عامًا
في الشهرين المقبلين ، الأطفال
الذين هم في المدرسة الابتدائية من
ستة إلى اثني عشر عامًا ،
لن يتمكن هؤلاء الأفراد على الأرجح
من الحصول على اللقاح
حتى تنتهي تجاربهم والتي من
المحتمل
أن تكون في أقرب وقت  هذا العام
في خطاب حديث إلى البيت الأبيض ،
تحث الأكاديمية الأمريكية لطب الأطفال إدارة بايدن على
إعطاء الأولوية
لترخيص اللقاح للشباب قائلة إنه
لا يمكننا السماح
للأطفال بأن يكونوا فكرة لاحقة عندما يكونون
قد شاركوا الكثير من
العبء خلال هذا الوباء من أجل
اللحظات الصحية.  م مندي جيثر